we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p you can call
anytime here's an interesting question
about sabotage or sabotage depending on
how you pronounce it take a listen
David this is Dave from California I
have a question do you think Donald
Trump yes does not want a second term as
president and the reason I'm asking is
this is behavior he's doing stuff insane
stuff about different people getting rid
of this person getting rid of that
person saying stuff about judges and all
this do you think he's trying to
convince the public not to vote for him
or he's just nuts listen I don't believe
that Trump's ego would allow him to
self-sabotage his reelection campaign we
know that when Trump first ran in the
Republican primary in 2016 he didn't
think he would win and he didn't have a
particular interest in being president
but he clearly overestimated the
intelligence of Republican primary
voters and he ended up as the nominee
now that he is president I don't believe
Trump's ego would allow him to say you
know this is kind of a mess I want to go
back to just eating you know taco salads
and KFC and Trump Tower and berating
window vendors on the phone to do the
deal for less money as much as that
might be appealing to him I don't
believe that his ego would really allow
him to deliberately tank his reelection
campaign now if you're saying is that is
any of this happening subconsciously I
guess it's conceivable that it is and in
that case it wouldn't be something that
Trump is deliberately doing but I don't
know I I don't think it's a particularly
likely explanation for what we are for
what we're currently seeing we've got a
great bonus show for you today we will
talk about the house passing an
anti-lynching bill and you might be
wondering anti how are they lynching
they're passing that in 2020 we will
explain we will also talk about the
Trump campaign filing a libel lawsuit
not a lawyer lawsuit a libel lawsuit
against the New York Times over a piece
last year related to Trump and Russia
and lastly we are going to talk about an
important endorsement an actual
important endorsement that Joe Biden got
in South Carolina specifically and Biden
is actually looking okay in some of the
upcoming primaries all of those stories
and much more on today's bonus show two
ways to get the bonus show number one
become a member at join pakman.com quick
easy you can save 66 percent with the
coupon code 2020 now the other way to
get access to the bonus show is become a
patron at patreon.com slash david pakman
show either way I will speak to you then
or tomorrow on the Friday show